هناك الكثير من المشكلات الصحيه المحتمله
بعد وقوع الزلزال فحوالي من اثنين الى 15%
يمكن ان يعاني من اصابات سحق من الاحمال
الثقيله التي تسحق اجسادهم هذا يمكن ان
يؤدي الى مشاكله فشل في الكلى وفي الحالات
الشديده حتى البتر اصابات العضلات والعظام
الاكثر شيوعا المرتبطه بالزلازل تتكون من
تمزقات وكسور وكدمات كما يعاني ضحايا
السحق من نسبه عاليه من التخثر المنتشر
داخل الاوعيه الدمويه ومتلازمه الطاقه
التنفسيه لدى البالغين كما يمكن ان يؤدي
تزاحم الناس وتجمعهم في المستشفيات او في
اماكن مبيت واحد بعد انهيار المنازل الى
زياده فرص انتشار الامراض الماضيه ويتعرض
الكثيرون لاضطرابات نفسيه بعد معايشه
الزلزال نتيجه فقدان الاحبه او صدمه
الحادث المفاجئ ما يجعلهم تحت وطاه اضطراب
ما بعد الصدمه بخلاف المشكلات النفسيه
الاخرى كالقلق والاكتئاب
الولد
[موسيقى]
امريكا